i
[Música]
ah
y aquí
[Música]
y cuál sería el trabajo de mis sueños
cuanto nos hemos hecho esa pregunta qué
quiero hacer que quiero traer al mundo
que quiero dejar en el mundo
y si no lo hicimos nosotros seguramente
hicieron siempre me llama la atención
ver cómo le hacemos la pregunta a los
chiquitos que quieres estar cuando sea
grande
y es que quieres ser lo que queréis
hacer
cuanto de nuestra identidad entra en
juego en relación a que elegimos hacer
en la vida
para manifestarnos
y cuando vamos creciendo y construyendo
nuestro camino
cuanto nos encontramos con la disyuntiva
será que voy armó algo mío yo emprendo y
voy a crear lo que yo quiera o el
trabajo para alguien
un empleo donde puedo crecer donde puedo
aprender
tenemos esas narrativas instauradas no
de que tenemos este camino o el otro con
sus pros y sus contras porque siempre no
voy a hacer lo que yo quiera no voy a
tener jefe no va a tener horario yo
tener riesgo
para tener también mucho trabajo
y si me voy para el lado de conseguir un
empleo que a tener más estabilidad voy a
ir creciendo tal vez mejor tranquilidad
económica pero que puedo estar dejando
en relación a lo que a mí realmente me
importa
hoy los quiero invitar
a recorrer un camino alternativo que no
sea uno o el otro sino uno
y si podemos crear un trabajo y tener un
trabajo en una organización que ya
existe donde estamos creando lo que
nosotros queremos lo que nosotros
queremos traer al mundo
hace 8 años me encontré con una palabra
que me ayudó a ser un reset y hace una u
otra forma de pensar sobre este tema
mientras emprender
entré a emprender quiere decir hacer una
nueva iniciativa nuevo producto o
servicio que a ti te importa que tiene
impacto positivo en la sociedad a partir
de una organización que ya existe
es un cambio de perspectiva porque hay
un lugar fundamental que yo no trabajo
para una organización yo trabajo desde
una organización
yo entiendo lugar en el que estoy
trabajando como una plataforma donde voy
a crear y armar un espacio no
simplemente a cumplir una descripción de
cargo
y porque esto es tan importante
porque si miramos la relación que
tenemos con el trabajo hay un estudio
que se hace todos los años por la
consultora internacional galo
se hace en más de 200 países y le
pregunta a las personas cómo se sienten
en relación a su trabajo
ocho de cada diez dice que no se siente
comprometido ni conectado emocionalmente
con su trabajo a pesar de dedicarle
en media ocho horas por día imagínense
el desperdicio de energía y de potencial
como personas que podemos ser más
felices y para las organizaciones que
puede ser que tengas colaboradores que
están con su cuerpo con su mente pero no
con su corazón y con su alma
imagínense cómo sería construir
organizaciones y plataformas donde nos
damos ese espacio sellamos seres humanos
mucho más felices organizaciones más
productivas y sostenibles y con
seguridad juntos podemos resolver los
grandes problemas de la sociedad si
enfocamos la energía para lo que
realmente nos importa
para mí eso es muy importante
el saber que podemos construir esa otra
narrativa de cómo organizarnos me da
esperanza
porque sólo viví en carne propia
para mí el trabajo siempre fue
importante con 19 años empecé a trabajar
en empresas
haciendo tal vez más de ser recorrido
tradicional y con 30 años estaba en un
momento difícil
había algo que no nos cerraba
era como que no tenía sentido 2007 río
de janeiro
estoy trabajando en una empresa que los
ojos de todo el mundo que excelente
desafiador que buen trabajo que
proyectos interesantes a mí no me decían
sentido
un día llego a casa después de 12 horas
de trabajo
zonas orando
y me dibujo como pajarito dentro de una
jaula
pajarito preso
esa imagen es tan fuerte que el otro día
fui
y loncar a mi jefe le dije sabes que yo
preciso espacio o sea yo preciso el
empleo pero pero preciso espacios me
puedes dar tiempo parcial para tener un
tiempo para para ver algo que tenga más
significado para mí
su reacción inmediata fue mira la verdad
que tiempo parcial podemos dar por un
asunto de familia por un asunto de
estudio pero tú crees tiempo para crear
algo que para ti tiene sentido
sí porque si no no estoy completa bueno
lo conseguí fue inédito pero me dieron
ese espacio
sin embargo ya no era suficiente
porque en mi caso mi cuerpo empezó a la
más fuerte y empezó a dar muchos
problemas de garganta para encantar me
cirugías pasar mucho tiempo sin hablar
y realmente conectarme no sé qué era lo
que yo quería hacer
y como me había perdido en ese camino
y opté por salir ir para ese camino va a
ser un revelador y realmente fue una
fase muy linda y creativa en mi vida
muy creativa porque tuve a mis dos hijas
maya y sofía y siempre digo que para mí
la maternidad fue como la explosión de
creación y armen dos empresas con socios
con negocios de impacto apoyando a
emprendedores todo lo que yo quería
estar
estoy cansada se agotaba 2013 estoy en
un momento así de profunda reflexión me
llamaban amigos que me decían que bueno
vos que saliste contame y te fuiste al
mundo emprendedor y yo pensando pero
estoy trabajando tantas horas y no
necesariamente haciendo todo lo que yo
quería es porque también la carga de la
estructura de las cuentas de la
administración
les decía esperar será que vos ahí
adentro si podéis pensar y construir lo
que vos querés no habrá una posibilidad
y me cruzo con esta palabra que para mí
fue un clic fue como que hubiera dado un
nombre y una narrativa
hace 7 años que me dedico a buscar entre
emprendedores gente que ya la está
practicando cuáles son las experiencias
cómo lo puedes hacer esto de construir
lo que vos querés en una organización
que ya existe
y comparto estas ideas tenemos una liga
de inter emprendedores somos una
comunidad internacional con miembros en
17 países que nos juntamos compartimos
las experiencias y la compartimos con
más gente porque creo que esta narrativa
nos puede ayudar a muchos a construir
nuevos caminos otra forma de
relacionarnos con nuestro trabajo y en
las organizaciones
y le quiero contar tres historias
que conocí en estos años que la verdad
que me inspiraron mucho una maría
fernanda en perú otra nick en áfrica en
kenia
y carolina en argentina
3 intraemprendedores que los tres
animaron hacer la pregunta y si y si
esto pudiera ser diferente
maría fernanda inicios de su carrera
consiga un empleo como analista de
comunicación en una pesquera en perú una
empresa tradicional que vende pescado ya
muy bien establecida en la costa
y en los pocos meses de estar trabajando
en esta empresa maría fernanda descubre
que hay un camión que va a una vez por
mes y dona pescado en la región serrana
donde las personas tienen bajos recursos
y muchas dificultades de desnutrición
pero fernando se pregunta y si ese
cambio no pudiera ir todos los días
y si de hecho podemos construir un
modelo donde llegamos y alimentamos esa
población un modelo que no sea donación
que sea financieramente sostenible
y recibe muchos nos porque la gente en
esa región no le gusta el pescado porque
no tenemos canales de distribución para
llegar con el pescado en condiciones y
porque como vamos a cerrar esta cuenta
acá no maría fernanda lo ve como un
desafío
y se compromete a crear a buscar que
sería posible y es así que en 2014
después de tanto no maría fernanda
consiguen lanzar tambos pesqueros una
iniciativa con mujeres emprendedoras
que llevan y enseñan recetas sobre cómo
comer pescado con financiamiento del
gobierno y multilaterales
qué logras al financieramente sostenible
y gana el premio este año pero 2021 como
uno de los proyectos de mayor impacto en
combatir la desnutrición y la buena
alimentación en el país
realmente nadie conoce a maría fernanda
de estos años trabaja más en la pesquera
pero dejó un legado y una construcción a
partir la oportunidad que sabía que era
posible que a realizar
ahora quiero invitar un poquito más
lejos y no para áfrica pequeña y conocer
la historia de niña
nik es un inglés que ha suministrado y
le ofrecen trabajar en kenia con una
empresa de celulares estamos hablando de
10 años atrás
nik sega y lo que les llama la atención
es que 70% de las personas tenías a un
celular en su mano y sin embargo cuando
se trataba de cómo transferir dinero aún
no hacían solamente en la mano
en esa pregunta
y si pudiéramos transferir dinero vía
celular
hoy capaz en 2020 nos parece obvio pero
en ese momento
la respuesta que tuvo muy rápidamente
fue uno
nosotros somos una empresa de celulares
no somos un banco
pero para mí ese no ya no era una
barrera porque lo había tocado desde
otro lugar que él quería construir y
entender si esto era posible empezó a
movilizar varias personas dentro de la
empresa y de la misma forma que maría
fernanda para buscar apoyo afuera y
consiguió que un fondo de inversión de
afuera de inglaterra invirtiese en su
idea y consiguieran hacer un piloto por
dos años para demostrar que esto tenía
potencial y es así que en dos años mitad
de la población de kenia
utiliza el sistema de transacciones
financieras empieza
esto es un caso de inclusión financiera
un caso que ha inspirado a tanta gente
en el mundo y se ha replicado tantos
otros países
pocos saben de nick de la misma forma
que maría fernanda el vio un camino en
esa plataforma y lo creó
y finalmente carolina carolina hasta la
argentina que reina es una comunicadora
nata nos conocimos hace dos años y es
aquella persona que viene de trabajar en
el mundo de marketing de consumo de
marcas
y le pasó lo ha parecido que a mí
después de varios años tuvo un momento
de reflexión y de crisis de cuál era su
misión bárbaro ya construida esa carrera
pero para qué para qué
y antes de largar
se propone tratar de usar esa capacidad
de movilización para algo que tenga
significado y es así que lanza la
campaña pega tú ves a que con una
botella de agua invita a comprar un
metro cuadrado de reserva natural
consigue movilizar 20 millones de metros
cuadrados de una reserva natural en
argentina y este este fue el inicio de
su carrera intra emprendedora porque
estos varias cosas más desde entonces
desde la plataforma donde trabaja
carolina nick maria fernanda
se conectaron
y se preguntaron
qué puedo hacer yo
con mi talento con mis valores con este
lugar donde trabajo para generar impacto
positivo en el mundo y yo también
realizarme en lo que a mí me importa
yo te invito a que te preguntes cuál es
tu bici
donde sea que estés
en el trabajo que tengas cuál es tu bici
y si sos dueño de una organización si
son líder
y tenés un grupo de colaboradores cuál
es el isi de cada uno de ellos y el
espacio que le puedes dar
[Música]